turning to politics we're getting the
strongest signal yet that former
president Donald Trump could soon be
charged with a crime Trump lashed out
again last night at prosecutors in New
York who are investigating an alleged
hush money payment to adult film star
Stormy Daniels and whether it was a
classified as a legal expense during his
2016 presidential campaign at O'Keefe is
in Washington Ed good morning Vlad good
to see you happy Friday the Manhattan
district attorney may be closing in on
Donald Trump marking what could be the
first time a former American president
he's charged with a crime as first
reported by the New York Times Trump has
been given the option to testify as soon
as next week before the grand jury it's
investigating business records involving
130 thousand dollar payment made to
adult film star Stormy Daniels days
before the 2016 election Daniels has
claimed she had an affair with Trump
something he denies the offer to testify
likely means criminal charges could be
on the way because New York state law
requires potential defendants be given
that option but Trump is likely to
decline the offer since January several
people close to the former president
have met with Manhattan prosecutors
including his former senior counselor
kellyanne Conway former communications
director hope Hicks and his former
attorney Michael Cohen who's at the
center of the alleged payments to
Daniels this may not be the only legal
challenge that he faces Georgia grand
jury remember recently recommended
several indictments according to the
four-person as prosecutors considered
charges in the possible interference in
the 2020 election the Justice
departments also got ongoing Federal
investigations but Trump has said all
three investigations are politically
motivated and he denies wrongdoing
telling reporters just last week that
even if he's indicted he plans to
continue his run for president Tony
yeah and then it'll be up to the voters
as it ever was Ed thank you very much